y hemos visto que los enantiómero son
estéreo y so menos verdad que no se
pueden superponer y además son imágenes
especulares el uno del otro y una forma
visual de decir cuando dos moléculas son
enantiómero so no es fijarnos en las
configuraciones en cada uno de sus
centros de calidad y si son opuestos
podríamos decir que son en anti o menos
y lo importante es que sean en cada
centro de quiralidad y también hemos
visto que los de asterio números son
esteroides o menos que no se pueden
superponer ni son imágenes especulares
el uno del otro verdad estos son los
días telómeros y una forma visual de
verlo es si sus configuraciones opuestas
son opuestas en algunos centros de
calidad y es en algunos no en todos
verdad en este vídeo vamos a
concentrarnos ahora más bien en los
compuestos meso y un compuesto menso es
un compuesto que tiene dos o más centros
de calidad pero en sí misma la molécula
es aquí así que vamos a usar esta
estructura de puntos
aquí como nuestro ejemplo para ver la
distinción entre estas definiciones
distintas de estas distintas
definiciones y si quisiera encontrar los
centros de calidad sabemos que por
ejemplo este carbono de aquí es un
centro de calidad y lo mismo pasaría con
este carbono de acá verdad
así que tenemos un total de 2 centros de
calidad en esta estructura de puntos y
txiki y si quisiera saber cuántos
estéreo isómeros posibles podría tener
tendría 2 elevado a la n donde es el
número de centros de calidad y en
nuestra estructura de puntos así que en
este caso tendríamos 2 elevado al
cuadrado que son cuatro posibles estéreo
isómeros distintos verdad así que vamos
a dibujar esas cuatro posibilidades
vamos a pintar primero nuestro anillo
ciclohexano
llegamos ahí está ahí nuestro h
i
h verdad bueno quizás
quizás antes de continuar con esto
debería más bien dejarlo así y poner
primero los cuatro anillos ok vamos a
poner estos cuatro anillos
el segundo
el tercero bien quizás no me están
saliendo muy bien pero bueno el punto es
que podamos distinguir de qué se tratan
estas definiciones anteriores entonces
en el primer caso podría ocurrir que
nuestro h esté apuntando hacia nosotros
verdad entonces ponemos una cuña
mientras que el segundo podría ser que
también esté apuntando hacia nosotros
verdad entonces ponemos otra cuña de
esta forma ahora bien en el segundo
ejemplo podríamos poner todo lo
contrario verdad que no esté apuntando
hacia nosotros si no hacia atrás digamos
de la hoja verdad y ahí estén los dos
coches o bien tenemos esta posibilidad
que uno esté apuntando hacia nosotros
ahí está este bache mientras que el otro
esté apuntando hacia atrás verdad y el
último ejemplo sería todo lo contrario
verdad de este primero estoy apuntando
hacia atrás mientras este de aquí esté
apuntando hacia nosotros aunque ella y
está en las cuatro posibilidades así que
vamos a analizar esto
2 de aquí muy bien vamos a analizar
estos dos que tenemos a la derecha ok
estos dos y si nos fijamos en sus
centros de calidad y en estos primeros
podemos fijarnos que en realidad en
estos dos primeros de arriba tienen
configuraciones completamente opuestas
lo mismo pasa para estos el centro de
calidad que tenemos aquí abajo entonces
si nos fijamos en nuestras definiciones
caerían muy bien dentro de la definición
del anti homero es verdad tienen
configuraciones opuestas en cada centro
de calidad lo único que tendríamos que
fijarnos es que estos no se pueden
superponer entonces estos dos de aquí
son enantiómero muy bien son en anti o
menos vamos a ver el siguiente par de
ejemplos a ver qué pasa si comparamos
estos dos de aquí ok entonces si nos
fijamos aquí podemos tener un aquí
tenemos un centro de calidad y aquí
también verdad entonces aquí podemos
observar que tienen una configuración
opuesta ahora sí analizamos este que
tenemos acá abajo
entonces podemos observar que no tienen
configuraciones opuestas de hecho son la
misma verdad entonces si regresamos a
las definiciones podemos ver que cae
bien dentro de la definición del de
asterio mero verdad tienen
configuraciones opuestas sólo en algunos
centros de calidad entonces estos de
aquí son días 0 días
tere o menos
creo menos muy bien y ahora sólo nos
falta por ejemplo no sé analizar estos
dos de aquí verdad vamos a ver qué pasa
en este caso tenemos por supuesto
podemos observar que para estos centros
de calidad tenemos configuraciones
opuestas lo mismo pasa para este de acá
abajo entonces en principio uno podría
decir bueno parece hacer que son
enantiómero sin embargo podemos notar
que estas dos moléculas en realidad son
la misma mira por ejemplo si nosotros
agarramos esta molécula que tenemos aquí
y la rotamos en esta dirección
digamos así entonces vamos a obtener
justamente la molécula que tenemos a la
izquierda entonces realmente son esta es
la misma molécula es la misma molécula
verdad solo que está vista desde
perspectivas distintas así que como
pudimos superponer la imagen espejo la
imagen especular sobre la molécula
original que teníamos en la izquierda
eso significa que es una molécula aquí
tal es aquí dalt y a pesar de ser aquí
tiene centros de calidad así que si
repasamos nuestra nuestras definiciones
verdad quede muy bien dentro de lo que
es un compuesto eso es un compuesto con
dos o más centros de calidad pero donde
la molécula es shakira le entonces estas
de aquí son meso y de hecho en principio
teníamos cuatro posibles es teórico -
pero sólo tenemos tres distintos verdad
estos dos en realidad son el mismo
otra forma de determinar cuando algo es
un compuesto eso es fijarnos en lo que
llamamos un plano de simetría así que si
nos vamos por ejemplo a este primer a
esta primera molécula nosotros podemos
dibujar un plano de simetría puedes
pensar que este plano
más o menos así y a través de ese plano
tenemos una simetría verdad es es
justamente la definición de un plano de
simetría y es lo que lo hace una
molécula akira al verdad y eso es una
prueba rápida para ver si es un
compuesto espeso ok entonces vamos a
hacer más
un último ejemplo para notar la
diferencia entre estas estas distintas
definiciones que tenemos aquí podemos
fijarnos en esta estructura de puntos
que tenemos acá arriba muy bien entonces
el primer paso como siempre es
identificar los centros de quiralidad
que en este caso ya lo he hecho por
ustedes previamente estos dos carbonos
son centros de calidad y te invito a que
hagas una pausa para que cheques por tu
propia cuenta que en efecto son centros
de calidad y bueno
como tenemos dos centros de calidad
podríamos esperar tener cuatro estéreo y
so menos verdad a lo más cuatro estéreo
isómeros así que he puesto ya también
los esqueletos digamos para que podamos
irlos construyendo muy bien entonces lo
único que hay que determinar es
si el h si los que tenemos aquí irían
apuntando hacia nosotros o hacia atrás
muy bien entonces vamos a ver vamos a ir
dibujando este primer caso en este
primer caso podríamos tener lo siguiente
que el este o h apunte hacia nosotros y
el hidrógeno restante apunte hacia atrás
mientras que del lado derecho puede
ocurrir que el hidrógeno apunte hacia
nosotros y él
apunte hacia atrás ahora bien si yo
quisiera dibujar lo que creo que es una
una imagen es reflejada de esto o bueno
si quisiera dibujar más bien el lo que
creo que es el enantiómero a este
compuesto todo todo lo que tengo que
hacer es invertir los centros de calidad
verdad entonces para el centro de
calidad que tenemos aquí abajo
tendríamos que él apunta hacia atrás
mientras que el hidrógeno apunta hacia
nosotros y en el caso contrario sería
digamos en este centro de quiralidad el
hidrógeno apunta hacia atrás mientras
que él
apunta hacia nosotros ahora bien en el
último ejemplo bueno estos son los que
creo que son los que podrían ser en anti
o meros ahora en el siguiente caso
podríamos poner los dos o los dos
hidroxi los apuntando hacia nosotros
verdad entonces aquí estaría uno y aquí
estaría el otro y que darían los
hidrógenos en este caso verdad y en este
caso sería todo lo contrario verdad que
los hidroxilo se estén apuntando hacia
atrás ok y los hidrógenos estén
apuntando hacia nosotros y ahí tenemos
nuestros cuatro posibles es teorizó -
así que vamos a analizarlos un poquito
más para ver las relaciones mucho mejor
ok entonces si nos fijamos en la primera
molécula que tenemos a la izquierda
vamos a fijarnos por ejemplo en este
en este carbono que tenemos aquí
nosotros sabemos que los enlaces sigma
verdad admiten rotaciones entonces
podemos hacer una breve rotación
alrededor digamos de este eje y lo que
vamos a observar es más o menos lo
siguiente aquí tenemos
en la cee verdad corresponde al h
dije no verdad
tenemos este otro enlace esto sigue
estando igual verdad no cambió nada que
ahí tenemos este esta cuña o h el
hidrógeno apuntando hacia atrás pero a
la hora de rotar este eje vamos a lograr
que este enlace que tenemos aquí pase
hacia arriba verdad luego tendríamos
este enlace doble hacia acá y finalmente
el enlace del h apuntando hacia la
derecha entonces qué es lo que va a
cambiar va a cambiar la orientación o la
configuración que tenemos aquí bueno no
tanto la configuración sino va a cambiar
el arreglo espacial y como es lo que
cambia si nosotros rotamos tú puedes
agarrar tu modelo tridimensional y ver
que entonces él
termina apuntando algo así hacia
nosotros verdad entonces de hecho si
cambia la configuración aquí estaría el
bache este de aquí
mientras que el hidrógeno ahora apunta
hacia atrás verdad y entonces esta
molécula que solo fue haber rotado
alrededor de este eje admite ahora sí
aquí un plano de simetría verdad aquí
podríamos poner un plano algo así que en
realidad es un plano de simetría verdad
se ve lo mismo del lado izquierdo que
del lado derecho así que este compuesto
en realidad es aquí y por lo tanto es un
compuesto eso verdad tiene dos centros
de calidad y además un plano de simetría
así que es un compuesto mesh hoy es una
forma muy rápida para esta rotación es
una forma rápida para dibujar el plano
de simetría verdad eso significa que su
imagen especular que es la que tenemos
aquí acá del lado derecho verdad se
puede superponer sobre la molécula
original así que ésta también va a ser
un compuesto eso vamos a ver qué pasa
con el otro ejemplo bueno si hacemos la
misma idea si si empezamos digamos vamos
vamos a ver este ejemplo cómo es con
respecto a este otro si nosotros hacemos
la misma idea de rotar alrededor de este
enlace que es lo que vamos a poder
observar pues vamos a poder observar del
lado izquierdo prácticamente lo mismo
los enlaces que corresponden a esta zona
digamos de la molécula vamos a poner
este en la cuña correspondiente al h
o el hidrógeno y este enlace de verdad
al rotar lo que podemos observar y te
invito a que hagas tu modelo molecular
en tres dimensiones es que ahora el
hidrógeno va a estar aquí verdad
apuntando hacia nosotros mientras que el
h apunta hacia atrás muy bien y
finalmente tendríamos el resto de los
enlaces justo como en el caso anterior
entonces aquí podemos observar
rápidamente que este no tiene un plano
de simetría y por lo tanto este
compuesto no es mes o verdad este es un
compuesto quiral y por lo tanto tiene
una imagen especular que no se puede
superponer sobre ella verdad entonces
estos dos son enantiómero así que vamos
mejor a ir circulando estas relaciones
esta molécula de aquí junto con esta
molécula de acá
enantiómero es verdad estos dos son en
anti o menos el uno del otro
no podemos hallar planos de simetría y
no son no se pueden superponer verdad
así que en el ejemplo que teníamos
anteriormente estos de aquí estos son de
hecho son la misma molécula verdad y por
lo tanto son compuestos meso verdad
porque pudimos encontrar nuestro plano
de simetría y por lo tanto sus imágenes
especulares se pueden superponer la una
sobre la otra verdad y eso es lo que los
hace un compuesto me so y por lo tanto
tenemos un total de tres estéreo
isómeros para esta estructura de puntos